in league of legends
support players fight an uphill battle
in a thankless role
their job is to protect their 80 carry
during the laning phase
literally to make someone else look good
and they sacrifice farm and sometimes
their own lives
to make that happen
but there's a champion that shows
everyone including the fans
that support players aren't the weakest
link
come out and play
he may not be focused on healing or
defending allies
but support players who pick thresh
don't care about those things
because when you have a hook and godlike
reeds
everyone on the enemy team is already
dead
they just don't know it yet
[Music]
[Music]
before league of legends season 3
support champions were a pretty mixed
bag
as players continued to figure the game
out some were played to help initiate
fights some were more standard
enchanters and others poked the opponent
in lane in some niche cases like nunu
they had abilities that buffed the 80
carry
so much that they were played as
supports even if that hadn't been the
design intention get up and he's forced
out templar back man mad life tried to
support him and they'd have to use his
ultimate to keep him away gets the
walmart stuff he's going to go down
first
and blitzcrank gave supports the chance
to make a big play
that could bring immediate results he's
going to flash away and auto attacks
from space coming with the gunslinger
passive
still looking for archie hits the hook
gotta pull him back he's flashing out
space gets the piercing line
but for the most part early on in league
of legends
supports were often walking ward bots
who did little more than help their
teammates carry the load
until january 2013 when players got
their hands on
thresh the chain warden
the champion was built from the ground
up as a support and his kit
was a playmaker's dream comes out from
nick and reckless is he going to go down
there's a protection from orion
he took the lantern he managed to get
away and they got the shoot down on nick
diamond goes down as well wouldn't you
believe it
between death sentence
dark passage
and flay thresh's kit
was at its core untapped movement
potential
all of it could reposition either
enemies or allies to create kills for
his team
and deny them to enemies the bottom lane
dive though looks like it's in the eyes
the hook
a lot of damage through the ignite on
early on as well they're not quite gonna
get him he stays alive finally first
play the hauntzer
anything on the way out rush looks
adrian as well lantern's there oh my god
are you kidding me but there's another
dimension to thresh's appeal
unlike many other supports he wasn't
sparkly
shiny or quirky he was scary
suddenly playing a support could also
mean being a badass
incarnation of death itself
[Music]
instead of waiting for the right moment
to protect his carry
thresh stalked the lane like a pale
green revenant
looking for a moment of weakness to
exploit
every movement and adjustment was a
potential opening for a huge play
that could instantly secure a kill the
fear of the chain warden's long reach
hung like an oppressive fog over his
lane
and if that hook landed and that chain
tightened
his opponent was being dragged down to
their end just another soul
collected in his lantern
in a cool nod to esports history
thresh's name
is an homage to dennis thresh fong the
quake pro who pioneered the wasd
keyboard layout and won john carmack's
ferrari
at red annihilation in 1997. thresh
instantly made a splash across the game
but there were two pro players who took
the champion to the next
level in those early years spreading the
chain wardens reign of terror
far and wide thresh's first acolyte to
become
known as a god was mad life a korean
support player
his blitzcrank was already highly touted
so everyone knew he could throw a hook
this one
was just a little more evil
[Applause]
but mad life didn't just show thresh's
mechanical depth
he did something even scarier blitz is
going to be able to have a chance to
come back
one suck again getting caught a bit how
does he hit every single one
madlife's predictive hooks are
immortalized by the player base itself
any hook that hits an opponent that used
movement abilities like flash
is still known to this day as a mad life
hook
what a bad life and at his core
it's something like the mad life moniker
that makes thresh so unique among
support champions
his introduction to the game created the
kind of personality around the support
position
that we've since learned to love about
other characters
like lee sin rise or leblanc
mad life quickly became known as one of
the game's brightest support stars
something that was a bit of an oxymoron
in the game's early years
and his flashy plays inspired people
including invictus gaming's baulon
to consider the support role and the
gruesome
impact a talented thresh player could
have on the bot lane
everybody is there though oh the bandage
talks barely based without flash does
that
man coming in as well thresh was
picked or banned in over 60 percent of
games at world season 3.
by 2014 the champion was clearly a
strong pick
in the hands of a mechanically inclined
support
and mata another korean superstar was
showing
unbelievable thresh play alongside the
more typical
enchanter supports as well as part of
samsung white
mata wasn't simply a chaperone to the
team's ad carry
imp he was a hunter known for roaming
with his jungler dandy
at a time when this was far rarer than
today
and he was an absolute terror in the
bottom lane
and in team fights especially when he
got his hands
on thrash decided to do when they sent
luke the top lane to get all this farm
here
fighting midlane amazing getting hit up
pretty hard he does get hooked in but
the rest of the team is there this could
be dandy going down
first block going to team solomid but
white has acted on this as well
a great flash over from lost boy but
that could feed daddy or pawn rather
exactly what he wants bjergsen's gonna
get knocked away
finalize the kill the ignite stairs
it's so close with the
hook from over the wall to save pond's
rear
samsung white became world champions in
2014
and mata became the first and only
support to become the tournament's mvp
and when it was time to pick his world
skin well
of course he picked thresh
[Applause]
but as the years went on mata didn't
always use
the skin in fact he saw it as something
he had to
continually earn and he was actually
interviewed and they said why do you
never use your skin
and he said well i don't think my
performance has been good enough to
justify using it
he used it once it's fun how little
things like that if he does play thresh
and he shows the samsung white skin at
this tournament
that will show you that he's ready to go
that he's read up and he's looking to
once again be the player that was on
everyone's lips after 2014.
thresh was popular at the 2015 world
championship
too the highest pick band percentage of
any support
in fact even among fans he was one of
the most popular
champions in the game by this point it
was
easy to see why the champion's iconic
visual and sound design had found
followers
even outside the game while on the rift
he was a
highlight machine that rewarded getting
inside your opponent's head
camping in a lot of people
he got it in 2017
looking back at the champion's design
then design director greg
ghostcrawler street felt thresh was one
of the finest champions riot had
produced
when you look in terms of support he's
always way up at the top
and i think that has a lot to do with
him delivering really well in a lot of
these different pillars
so let's talk about satisfying gameplay
i mean he has
a hook he has filet which is huge skill
curve at like getting that ability to
work correctly
he has the the box a lot of these are is
fairly hard to learn and and very hard
to master
but league changed and thresh's kit that
once seemed so
overloaded with options was increasingly
just
average so thresh definitely has certain
matchups that are not favorable
especially into poke or enchanter
supports
there are certain lanes certain matchups
that you just can't really interact with
that thresh can't all in and he will get
bullied out of lane and
in those matchups he's not as strong a
great historical example of this is
worlds 2016 where he wasn't picked at
all
and even into the next year although
some players were starting to pick him
up again in the summer
by the time we got to worlds 2017 we had
that infamous art and sensor meta the
enchanter support meta
you saw him drop off again still even if
the champion
wasn't considered top tier a gifted
thresh player
could always leave their mark even when
the odds are against them
yeah for me tsm 3-0 the problem that
we've seen highlighted by clutch even in
their most recent weeks they don't do
very much on the map they lost some
games where feby's literally sitting mid
pushing as his bot lane is getting dope
you need to have a more proactive
playstyle in the playoffs yeah i'll be
very surprised if clutch gaming wins
this series i'm going to sm3o trying to
get it accurate
in 2018 at the lcs spring playoffs
clutch gaming were down a game against
the heavily favored tsm
but clutch's support hakuho a long-term
member of the cabal of thresh
reminded everyone of the chain warden's
paralyzing gaze
lyra decides okay that's fine we're just
going to go for 50 mp
comes through and now both tsm bottom
laners gonna be in some trouble spin
still trying to walk away from this one
but apollo's got the damage one more
auto attack should do it
can he find it who rips the soul right
out of him
hanging around lyra there as well five
men now as mikki gets
pulled in and that's the kind of hook
you need
no big front line there for tsm hakuo
dsm's on the retreat feather then
looking for the never move not able to
find it on the bjerk
[Applause]
showed his thresh prowess even in the
late game but
tsm didn't respect it enough to ban it
specifically
so in two more games he made them regret
that decision
clutch gaming will be the first
organization
to deny them their path to the semis and
will earn their spot
in miami oh my goodness
history in the making on the stage here
today
clutch gaming ended tsm and hakuho's
thresh was a key part of it
it was a reminder that for those who
spend the time thresh
can carry games hawkwood was just going
insane with his point-and-click ability
basically just hooking people left and
right it was
it was absurd i mean i was not expecting
him to be able to pull off that kind of
a play
in 2019 the champion was back in the mix
and a big part of that
was fun plus phoenix's crisp as
fpx ran through the bracket at worlds
crisps thresh went undefeated
in four games and again despite that
it was never banned against him but tian
secures it there's the hook coming in
and cersei
already stunned up and locked down no
scavenge with the blast and we'll knock
them back the humanoids knowing the best
of shapes now lwx going low dodging
around as much as you can
comes out gpo doing a lot of work here
but don't be can step back forward
looking for the call the meek will heal
him up a bunch humanoid is down and now
no scavenger have to run for the hills
there goes that death charge the flash
comes up that's a fantastic kion
ultimate
bow lands gonna be the first to fall
here no it's actually wrong one two
three
invictus just get dumpstered for crisp
thresh was an outlet to express his
playmaking
and mechanical ability and it helped him
win a championship
and fun plus phoenix are your world
champions although he joked beforehand
that he would choose a pike skin to take
it away from g2 if he won
crisp picked thresh becoming the second
player in history to get a world skin
for the champion
even though newer champions might offer
even more
options or bulkier kits the skill
sealing of thresh
has continued to attract talented
acolytes
who bring his influence to the very top
level of competition
but not all supports even those with
world championships under their belts
immediately pledged their souls to
thresh some like
core jj had to be coaxed
before lcs summer 2020 core jj had
played the champion only a handful of
times on stage
but as he teamed up for his first season
with his new rookie adc
tactical core jj threw himself into a
champion
that he had mostly ignored i thought you
didn't like thresh either which i think
is funny that you just blind picked it
because
when i played with you you said that
thresh was just a whatever champion yeah
yeah
actually the timing my stretch was not
good enough i think you played with a
disadvantage i
see i see like my message got improved
since last year summerslam i think and
he was
actually incredible at it across summer
season and playoffs
thresh was one of core jj's most played
champions
with a 75 win rate and although he's
still
only got 20 career games under his belt
on thresh
he's already one of core jj's best
champions
in terms of win rate turning things
around here as tsm try to engage brox is
going to keep the rest of tsm occupied
broken blade is already killed
now impact still has the ulti to keep
this train a rolling
as the damage pours through into
bjergsen tactical grabs himself a double
kill
who needs a soul when you can take a
nexus
in the end maybe the most surprising
thing is that for a support as
accomplished and respected as core jj
it took so long for him to pledge
himself
to thresh but the chain warden has a
habit of
pulling you in
the champions played at the support
position are often dictated by
the meta but that's why thresh is so
special he's always a threat
his most faithful adherents will always
be ready
to lock him in and when they do they
remind us that
within every support that loves thresh
their
a monster
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages